but are you an Elon fanboy
not as much as your Joe Biden boy Fanboy
no because that you're you're a die hard
I would be interested if I would have
known
oh it's obvious you you love uh
seriously no what's not now why is it
seriously our new podcast said why do
you have a painting of Biden in the back
oh okay okay so all right okay go ahead
what is your thought because I was a
relatively early Tesla investor and I
still drive a Tesla I think it's going
to be my last one I've sold the shares
are where are you on Elon because a
couple people wrote to me they're like
oh uh Patrick's Fanboy or on Tesla
either okay so
can I take a sip yeah is that an energy
drink now it is owned by Tesla by the
way too yeah
no it's not I don't but by the way while
he's drinking this why are why are you
done with Tesla why is this your last
Tesla the reason and are you are not
Elon Musk Fanboy I have no emotional
thought whatever about Elon okay so here
was my thought okay when I got the Tesla
shares in 2015 I thought
Electric's coming early mover range and
charging network are the things that
matter this is gonna set them up they're
gonna it's gonna be crazy
so I bought the shares eventually I got
one of the cars I was like this is
fantastic once you buy shares when when
2015 26 February 2016 I think it was so
I get the car I'm like unbelievable
range fantastic the charging Network all
this stuff the build quality kind of
sucks everything's rattling there's
things that are held together seems to
be by tape but that's okay I like I get
it they haven't been building cars very
long they're gonna it's gonna improve
it's gonna improve got the second Tesla
better build quality still it's the same
issue four times now every time it's
literally something that has to be
ratcheted has to be taken apart now the
other companies that let's be honest
Audi builds better cars than Tesla
they've been doing it for a hundred
years they don't rattle Etc they're
losing the charging network advantage
slowly partially thanks to the inflation
reduction Act and the the high speed
here we go spokesperson for Biden and
also
um the range there's more and more cars
now that are matching the range so I
think the time that first mover
Advantage is diminishing drive so David
if if somebody didn't know either one of
us yeah and they had to pull yep to to
say who's a Elon Fanboy yeah it would be
you why here's why you're against all of
it can I can I can I answer why are you
such a bully let me answer man uh one
I've never owned the Tesla okay
two I don't own Tesla stock I've never
bought Tesla stock okay okay because I
thought it was always overpriced wow
okay uh but here's what I will tell you
please as a jockey I'm a fan of the
Jockey him being the jockey the business
I thought Tesla too many people who were
Fanboys who thought that it's just
because it's him it's going to kill it
it's down 85 for the Year by the way
sold but the point is it's at the right
number right now it's around the number
it should be give or take maybe it's
still not at the number it needs to be
but long if it's a long investment I
think it's a good long investment I
think a lot of people got killed last
year by the way a lot of people made you
know money last year as well Citadel Ken
Griffin made 16 billion last year you
don't make 16 billion during a flat
economy or even slightly down you make
it because you were shorting certain
stocks and some of the famous stocks to
short last year hence the company and
the boy you love the most you know your
guy Elon Musk okay
I'm out of the stock and I'm getting out
of the car so you're an ex-fan boy is
what you are it's okay I mean there's
nothing wrong with that the product yeah
was had a specific Advantage never been
a ton of the product I've never been a
fan of the product I've never been one
that has gone my but by the way my best
one of my best friends every time he
named this sunny lawn well that's
qualified okay he owns Teslas
stocks all of it total fan of that stuff
I'm not that camp yeah what I do like is
the following just so you know when you
leave this place you best say thank you
to Elon okay you owe him a thanks okay a
big things have you enjoyed the the
session we've had today together yeah is
this a good day for you yeah I mean
listen I don't know that I think we
talked past each other a lot okay and
things that are not actually
disagreements were zoomed in on and and
I think we would actually get along on
80 of stuff if the conversation was not
for television potentially did you watch
Kyle's uh uh show when Kyle and I were
together or no I watched some of it okay
you know how much fun I had with Kyle no
it's the same I had a lot of fun with I
have no idea how much fun by the way if
you told me you are willing to come back
next month you're on next month I I
enjoy the sauce so you don't one thing
you need to know you should I don't look
at comments anymore the comments on this
from your audience are going to be
brutal I'm going to need a new therapist
I'm gonna need a new therapist I
actually think I actually think they
like you a lot of as well trust me and
here's why they're with our audience the
reason with our audience is because we
like people like that to come we don't
want like by the way you know who's
going to be on Thursday you ready for
this one I I don't know like the
complete opposite yes it's going to be
Ben Shapiro
is it worse James O'Keefe is going to be
on Thursday from uh from uh Veritas oh
my God yeah so he's going to be honest
but if I'm sure you guys would like to
have lunch together and have a good time
together I'll still be here I'll swing
by so but but here's the point here's
the baby we said something the point the
point I want to make too is on on the
topic of differences and all you said he
was gonna has to thank Elon for
something yeah because without Elon you
and I wouldn't have tweeted each other
he's running Twitter right now uh
talking about we tweeted each other last
year I know we did but you know again
what does that have to do with Elon it's
a connection we have through Twitter
that he's running now
a year ago it had nothing to do with
matter man I'm giving this guy credit
because it's the bad boy to find a
reason to thank Elon for something
listen I have a little attitude I'd like
to find reasons to be thankful for
people right now who is a bigger Elon
Musk Fanboy there is no way or Patrick
but but if you want to say like in an
area that I believe in what he's gonna
do as a jockey okay yeah I I believe in
him as a jockey so if if I'm gonna if
I'm on a long anything I'm on a long
what he's gonna be doing investment by
the way I really appreciate the metaphor
that you're using right now
of the horse versus the jockey the horse
in this instance
I agree with that's inaccurate guys we
are finding common grounds so if you
like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]